hello everybody markiplier here to
answer your questions and also have a
decision on what I'm gonna do about
happy wheels but that's that's later on
I've got a few more questions that you
guys have been asking me and I've been
trying to get to them then I haven't
been doing as many V logs as I'd like
but or as you like or any at all because
I've been busy with games you know what
this channel is all about but anyway
I'll just start with the first question
here which is what keyboard does Mark
use I still use this crappy um $10
keyboard you know I'm I'm a frugal guy I
don't like to spend where I don't need
to spend so in a lot of ways I just kind
of deal with what I have for a while
until it breaks on me and if it doesn't
break then you know I'm still good so
this is how I live my life I don't feel
the need to spend money on anything that
I don't need I'd rather put that towards
useful stuff but anyway second question
wait
so in the livestream just now you said
this obviously back then your brother
was two kinds his name is Thomas but
yeah that's his webcomic as in that
comic that's being slowly written yeah
he is
my brother is Thomas Fishbach he is the
writer of the comic too kind too kind
keen spot net he's pretty popular like
more popular than I am by far but yep
that's him
I think I've answered that question
before actually number three do I have a
favorite animal not really you know
nothing really stands out and kind of
like dogs and cats and wolves are cool I
suppose lions are neat you know all that
sort of stuff but
because maybe the platypus that's an
interesting animal what is his diopter
diet di opt re which I think is the
strength of my lenses I actually don't
know but you can these are specially
designed to be much thinner and they're
still kind of thick but they're not that
bad but my sunglasses you can actually
tell how bad my eyes are because of how
thick these sunglasses are they're like
they're like busting out of the rims
here they're gigantic so anyway that's
my I don't know the exact number but I
wouldn't be able to give that to you
anyway cuz I don't think I even have it
written down anywhere can I donate with
paysavecard 's in marks livestream I'm
not exactly sure I think all of my
donations right now are set up to go
through PayPal but PayPal does allow you
to use cards if they're associated with
your account so I don't really know
you'll have to do some more research on
that the head since I got we're probably
the cheapest to do head since I could
find their audio technica ath M 30s
they're they're pretty high quality I
mean they're better than any that I've
had before and I can plug them directly
into my microphone which means I can
hear myself as I'm talking which is very
beneficial
are you considering going to other
conventions than just comic-con like PAX
Magfest exit cetera I am but that's all
gonna have to wait until next year
because as I've said before I'm not in
the greatest of financial situation so I
don't have enough money to just start
throwing around on plane tickets and
hotels so but once I get you know more
steady into youtube I get more popular
you know I'm starting to have a an
actual income that I can live off of
that's when I would start branching out
because it's something that I want to do
I want to go do these things and I want
to meet fans I want to meet you guys I
really do so look forward to that but
later on down the road probably past the
point where I hit a hundred thousand
subscribers that's when I'd start to get
really serious about traveling around
the country um have you ever had an
interest in other video games than just
PC ones
I remember back my brother like for his
seventh birthday I think got a Super
Nintendo Entertainment System in SNES
and that was probably the best console I
could remember I remember playing the
crap out of that one me and my brother
would just you know we played rampage
together in Super Mario Brothers and we
played all sorts of game earthbound
which apparently couldn't sell for a lot
of money and I still have my original
earthbound I still have my original
earthbound guidebook that's how old that
is but I loved flipping through that
thing it's kind of falling apart now but
apparently that's worth a lot of money I
don't really know I wouldn't sell it
anyway it's worth it means too much to
me that Super Mario RPG was a great game
so if I had to say anything it's the
original Super Nintendo Entertainment
System it's just you know fantastic
I can't imagine memories being better
than that because you know gaming has
been a part of my life for a long time
so I just can't imagine being without it
you know that's a big chapter in my life
for consoles but then I moved onto PC
after that so nothing else I mean the
n64 was kind of cool but I didn't really
play that that much um what hobbies do I
have outside of gaming um you know every
summer me and my group friends we get
around we play football
whatever usually I don't really have any
hobbies per se gaming has always been my
main hobby but as of lately I've been
playing it as a hobby less because it's
becoming my job and it's kind of sad in
a way because you know you do something
you love for a living and that's what my
life is turning into but then you
realize that that thing you love isn't
as special anymore because you have to
do it for other people and it takes away
some of it yeah I think I do have to
find another hobby
going out of my mind working on the
channel you know I spend basically every
waking hour of mile every waking minute
of my life thinking about the channel
that's kind of obsessive but I think
that's part of the reason why we've been
so successful is because I care so much
about um the community that I'm growing
and I think every day how can I make it
better you know it's something that I
absolutely love to do and it goes back
to you know the hobby thing I don't mind
playing video games for you guys I don't
at all it's probably the greatest thing
I could ever imagine doing for a living
so you don't have to worry about that
I'm not sad at all that I have to play
video games you know so what is my
favorite book I used to read the
Dragonlance Chronicles a lot that would
have to stand out in my head I used to
love that you know Carmen and his
brother Raja jaja was I can't even it's
been a long time since I read but the
two brothers you know that whole dynamic
really rang with me because me and my
brother have always been really close so
I've always kind of related to any story
that has a strong brother time that
that's just the whole story the whole
dragon lands stories all wrapped
together pretty well but I haven't been
reading as much as I want to I actually
like to read I really do I also like to
write you know I have dreams I want to I
want to write a book someday
I really do I've got ideas in my head
that I need to get out I've written
short stories before I used to be on
not what was the name of the website I
think it was just writing dotnet or
something like that not fan of fiction
or anything like that but stories
dot-com I don't remember what it was but
there was a website where you could just
put stories up and you know people would
see in peer review and all sorts of
stuff like that so writings something
that I want to get into more I need to
like save up to get you know just a
little small little laptop that I can go
outside of my house and write with that
that's kind of important to me do I like
point and click games like Monkey Island
no no not really I don't have the
patience for that and that's part of the
reason why I'm not really into the sort
of games where I have to run around and
make sure I click everything to
everything because if I somehow miss
like some small detail then that kind of
throws a wrench in my plan tonight I
kind of feel like I lose interest so I'm
sorry to say I've never actually played
monkey on I know I should it's a good
game from what I've heard and you know
yeah there are certain games that are
kind of like iconic and Monkey Island
has always been one that's iconic for a
lot of people if you're too young to
remember what it is or know what it is
it's an old game made back in the 90s
early 90s but then they updated it and
there's new editions out and all sorts
of stuff like that but it isn't
currently a very good game I like missed
miss was great you know missed Riven or
one of the sequel examples I love miss
Nova grab a nice banana that's all the
questions that I ever know I didn't say
that very finely so thank you for your
questions that's all the questions that
I have for now now the point that I want
to make about the happy wheel sing now a
lot of you know if you've watched I
yesterday I put up a video of me playing
happy wheels and it got you know a lot
of mixed reviews but I asked for that
I'll ask for your honest opinions and a
lot of people liked it but then again a
significant number of people that
and they gave good reasons for it um so
what I was thinking is that you know it
was the same way with you know when I
did him people concerned let me just
address a few of them I'm not worried
about hate you know I dealt with hate
when I started out on this channel I
started out with amnesia and everybody
in their grandma did amnesia
everybody did I got so much hate I got
death threats
you know people sent me emails just
saying like how dare you copy
PewDiePie obviously how dare you copy
every other person that's ever done
horror in their life and how dare you do
this you don't deserve to do this but
you know that never bothered me I'm
serious I got death threats we were like
I will come find you and kill you if you
keep doing this you don't deserve to do
it bla bla bla bla bla and you know it
got me down back then but then I realize
you know I I can do this better than
people you know there's no game out
there that only one person is ever going
to play and I realize that you can
either innovate innovate or imitate and
I've kind of found a way of my own to
play games but that's getting off
subject what I want to say is I
understand your concerns about happiness
and I don't think that I should keep it
up as a let's play you know I don't
think I should keep it as an ongoing
series but at the same time a lot of
people do like it I stayed away from it
for a long time I have an idea though of
something that I could do that could
make it interesting you know not turn it
into a drinking game because you know a
lot of people almost every channel
there's tons of channel thousands even
they have minecraft in that try to do
Minecraft Let's Plays and I I tried I
knew that going into it
well me and Bob and Wade did the drunk
minecraft and we did something different
something that no one ever does you know
no one gets drunk and plays Minecraft on
a regular basis that's that's now an
iconic thing that I do so I want to make
an acai connick thing that I do for
happy wheels because to be perfectly
honest I never laughed harder when I saw
good replays of guys just getting ripped
apart for no reason and happy was it's a
funny sing back four years ago when I
first played it it was the funniest
thing in the world to see these people
just explode into pieces I laughed my
ass
at some of the scenarios so what I want
is I want to bring that back and I don't
want to give it as a regular series what
I want to do is I want to have something
special that's not even on a weekly
basis it's not that often what I want to
do is I want to you know I want to play
happy wheels and I'm going to want to
record myself going for about an hour or
longer
you know just long time playing in a big
session and what I'll do after I do that
is I will take the best part I will you
know distill it down into its funniest
moments and so that every single video
that I put out will be minecraft a
nomogram happy wheels highlights and
these wouldn't even be that often now it
wouldn't be like I liked his ni put you
know subtitles and I don't have time for
that but it would be something special
it would be something different like
everyone does happy wills I know this I
know this very much you don't have to
remind me of that but I think that
there's something to it still happy
wheels is still a fun game and if I can
take the content and just get rid of all
the fluff not make it a let's play
series where I do 150 episodes of this
stupid game ican't Reich I control the
flow of the game and I crunch it down
into the best parts like only the best
parts I'd take an hour and I'd smash it
down to less than five minutes
I would only take the very very best
bits and crunch it down and mash it into
a five minute or less segment that you
all can enjoy that way the people that
do think I do a good job at playing
happy wheels enjoy it and get to watch
something get to watch the funniest
moments ever
and then the people who don't like happy
wheels and I understand there's quite a
few of you out there you don't have to
watch it because it doesn't take up that
much time I still have my um small indie
horror games that I play and I really
like to play these small indie horror
games I still have the regular you know
and these are custom stories that I do
cry fear
the new games that come out the non
horror games like Dishonored I still do
that and then I have these itty-bitty
videos that come off every other week or
so of the funniest moment of high
highlights from happy wheels that I can
find I think that's a good compromise
because you know I shied away from it
but there are a lot of people that
enjoyed the video like I think the ratio
is it the moment I'm making there's well
over 500 likes and there's like
something like 40 something dislikes I'm
not a good teacher I haven't checked in
a bit but you know that's significant
that's the mode it's it is one of the
highest like videos I've had but it's
also the most disliked videoed I've had
and I think that's pretty good to say
that I own I hope there's only one video
that has a significant number of
dislikes like that yeah maybe not I
should check I don't think it might be
be the absolute highest dislike but it's
pretty close if it's not there so I'm
listening I'm trying to come up with a
compromise that both of both of the
groups can agree on because it's not
gonna take up a huge number of my time
but it still gives the people that enjoy
the content that they love and in a
better form so let me know what you
think of that I really want to get you
guys his opinion on on this whole idea
also give me your questions I will I
would like to keep up a regular thing
where I regularly answer you guys a
question these don't have to be regular
questions like you know oh where were
you born you know it doesn't have to be
like that it can be like you know weird
ponderous questions like what would
chairs look like if your knees were
backwards you know interesting questions
like that so ask me anything anything at
all write in the comments below I'll
compile a list for the next video and
hopefully I can start doing these more
regularly because I like to interact
with you guys I like to get the dialogue
going between us because I feel like the
more people I have the harder I have to
work to make sure that you guys know
that I care and I do I care so much I
care
unbelievably about I'm so proud of what
we've managed to do together because
that's what's important
working together to make a better place
whether it's donations whether it's
charity whether it's a better community
just between us you know for better
laughs and no better thing so let me
know what you guys think about my happy
wheels idea write me all your possible
questions if you have multiple comments
if you have two and try to keep it in
you know one question for comment don't
list six in a comment so if you have
multiple questions please write multiple
because easier for me to get one
question at a time and I will say your
name obviously and thank you guys so
much for everything you've done
thank you for just letting me do this
for you I want to work together I want
to get your opinions I want to know what
you want and I also want to give what
you want but I also want to do what I
want to do so it's compromised and it
needs an open dialogue so thank you guys
so much for watching and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye